found and East in southwestern Africa
this is achieved now that's more like
this is a cheetah it's doing what
cheetahs do best running flat out after
prey a cheetah is the fastest land
animal zero to forty five and 2.5
seconds top speed up to 64 miles an hour
when you look at a cheetah you're more
likely to think spotted greyhound than
you are big cat I mean look at that body
small head large chest tiny waist
clearly built for Sprint's rather than
marathons weighing 75 to 145 pounds
a cheetah stands up to 3 feet tall at
the shoulders
cheetahs hang in small groups called
coalition's a lot of times this is a
band of brothers only the dominant
coalition member gets to mate when the
time comes
usually when females turn to three
months after these speed demons do the
deed
the Cubs arrive within two months
they're backing up mom and sharing the
spoils of her kills cheetahs pursue such
animals as gazelles wildebeest calves
impalas and smaller hoofed animals they
run them down and make their kill with a
bite to the jugular
cheetahs are an African master of fast
food because they're a much smaller cat
than the lions and leopards we just saw
they have to run fast kill fast and eat
fast before other carnivores try to move
in on their kill only about nine to
twelve thousand cheetahs remain in the
world and that's not a statistic to
Yanam